WINNIPEG BENCH.
BOTH OF THESE TEAMS ARE HIGH STT
D
OF THE SEASON A YEAR AGO WITH
THE EXTRA MAN, FACE UP TO THE
RIGHT CONTROLLED BY THE.
>> John: JOSH MANS PRETTY IMPORT
PLAYOFF GAMES.
>> John: BLAKE WHEELER'S ONE
TIME OR DISRUPTED
CONNOR GOES TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
CIRCLE WITH IS
A BREAK FOR GAME YEARS OF AGE.
>> Brian: IT TOOK HIM A LITTLE
WHILE TO GET HIS FEET WET IN THE
NHL.
OARDS AND FRANKLY HE
JUST THROWS IT AT THE A
200-FOOT PLAYER, HE PLACED BOTH
ENDS OF THE OPENS
TONIGHT IS THE FOURTH LINE
CENTER..
HE CAN ABSENTLY FLY -- THAT'S A
GOOD STOP BY JOHTALKING ABOUT H,
REMEMBER HE HAD THREE SHUTOUTS
EARLY IN T T
THAT'S WITH THE FACE-OFF COMESYS
RINK WIDE WITH IT, HERE IS
BRENDEN DUCKS HAVE A GOAL ON
THEIR ONLY SHOT ON GOAL, THEY
WOULD LOVE TO SPEND A LITTLE
TIME IN FRONT OF CONNOR PUCK ANS
IT AROUND THE GAME,
THAT IS GREAT MATERIAL FOR A IN.
HERE COMEMBERED ATTACK
THAT HAUNTS ANAHEIM HERE.
THE PLATE AT THE JETS HINK WIDE.
THE OVERLOAD
AROUND.
WINNIPEG.
>> Brian:
HE WINS THE PUCK BACK AND
MASON
McTAVISH.
>> John: HE GOT HIT BY BRENDENNE
EARLIER IN THAT SHIFTL TURN INTE
BATTLES WON TO KEEP PUCKS ALIVE.
WATCH RIGHTE PENALTY KILL HELD R
LOOK.